لا تتوقف حركه السفن المحمله بالحبوب في
مضيق البسفور مكان الامر ليحدث لولا اتفاق
اسطنبول الذي رعته تركيا بوساطه امميه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا
اتفاق جنب العالم ازمه غذائيه وعاد على
انقره بمكاسب دبلوماسيه واقتصاديه فاذا
كبيره بالنسبه لتركيا على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي والسياسي والاعلامي حتى للصعيد
الداخل تركيا تستوعب صادرات اكثر او
واردات اكثر من قبل اوكرانيا وروسيا
للحبوب اضافه الى اسعار مخفضه الاموال
التي ستحصلها من العبور حتى السفن التركيه
التي اجرت ربما ايضا كان لها عائد الملك
ليس هذا فحسب اذ تطمحوا انقره الى التحول
الى مركز لتصدير الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا
ما يدير الكثير من العوائد على الخزينه
التركيه لا يفوت الرئيس التركي فرصه الا
ويركز على مساعد تحول الى مركز لتجميع
الغاز الطبيعي وتصديره الى اوروبا
بسبب موقف تركيا المحايد من الحرب ووجود
امدادات الغاز نرى ان تركيا ستحقق في مجال
الطاقه
والغازان تركيا
غازة وسيكون لتدفق الغاز عوائد على
الخزينه التركيه
تسهم في حل مشكله العجز في الموازنه
بعد عام على بدء الحرب تجنبت انقره الى حد
كبير ما تعانيه اوروبا من تاثيراتها بل
وجنت منها اقتصاديا بتحولها الى ثاني اكبر
مصدر الى روسيا واكثر الوجهات الاستثماريه
للروس